last question today Hey what is
something that you admire or find
redeeming about conservatives oh boy
think about that one I mean I think that
if I had to say as a general thing
something I find I don't know about
redeeming but something I admire about
conservatives is how can I even word
this I want to be careful in how I
worded they are often willing to get out
there and advocate for what they believe
is right I'm even cringing as I say it
because I would say the same thing about
any political activists but like the tea
party are you thinking I don't know like
just conservatives yeah I'm not against
abortion but conservatives who are
against abortion they go out there and
they advocate for that and it's
admirable to advocate for what you
believe in like I don't know I'm really
pretty much at a loss here but I guess
is that like a totally generic and
meaningless thing I can say I admire in
the interests of bipartisanship or
something I don't know it's it's hard to
come up with because there are so many
conservatives in the country and so many
liberals in the country one thing I
would think of is that they tend to get
things done like if you think back to
Obama's first two years in office even
though he had a supermajority in the
Senate and he had the majority in the
House right what did we get from that
not too much the lilly Ledbetter the
Affordable Care Act in some form but
these these two years under Trump I mean
it started out a little bit impotent a
little bit incompetent now it seems like
they're doing whatever they want well
under the cover of obsession with Trump
and media you mean in some way that
Republicans are able to actually is
legislation passing legislation yeah
what about I mean this is just a tough
question what do I admire about
conservatives what about that I admire
that they've been effective at the local
level like I think that the peep the
success they've had at the local level
is disgusting and I think it's been one
of the biggest failings of the left that
Republicans have had a really good sort
of farm team which then they put in
state legislatures and state Senate's
and then eventually those people rise up
to become maybe holders of higher
political office I admire it I think
it's horrible and I'm completely against
it but the successes
they've had at the very local level and
in training Young Conservatives and
putting money towards you know
developing young conservatives who can
speak at least what appears to be
somewhat eloquently about their issues
that is something I wish the left would
do in it and I've been critical of the
left for not doing it
how about how they don't really
apologize or think they don't have to I
don't admire that no I don't admire it
now that's just I mean now what what's
admirable about that well if they don't
look weak in the eyes of the public I
think and the public will still rally
behind them you're saying that it might
have might be politically advantageous
never to apologize I don't admire it
though it could be politically
advantageous but I don't admire the fact
that conservatives seem unable to take
responsibility for their misdeeds do you
would you say the Conservatives are by
and large polite I mean you you have the
image of them as these like people in
three-piece suits who are well put
together and maybe they advocate for
policies that we disagree with but look
at conversation look at my Twitter feed
YouTube comments and email and you will
see that I would have no experience
to have the stereotype of conservatives
that they're polite now this is perhaps
the toughest audience question of all
time for you it is really difficult it
is really difficult but I I hope I've
done the question at least some justice
what do you admire about conservatives
if you're a progressive let me know
either in the youtube comments or on
twitter at deep Ackman or by emailing me
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get access to the bonus show
instantly by signing up at join
pakman.com or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show